bienvenue bienvenue à tous ce mois-ci
paris saclay tv prend le bus mais
attention pas n'importe lequel
l'express 91,06 avec sa voix a réservé
permet une meilleure desserte du campus
ça va vous changer la vie
le bus une façon idéale de sillonner le
territoire d'aller à votre rencontre
le proto 204 ce lieu d'innovation de
paris saclay il pense très sérieusement
il veut lancer le proto bus on en débat
déjà ensuite nous allons prendre de la
hauteur avec le tout nouveau radar de
l'aviation civile effet 66 mètres de
haut
il va permettre de surveiller et de
guider les avions en région parisienne
nous avons assisté à la pose du radôme
vous allez voir c'est impressionnant
autant de projets de chantiers qui font
l'histoire de paris saclay du campus
paris saclay mr qui s'étudie déjà un
colloque barrios ap s'est tenue à
l'école polytechnique
nous y avons assisté et enfin l'agenda
ce sera à la fin de cette émission comme
promis embarquement immédiat à bord du
91 06 l'express 91,06 ce musée a pris du
galon il a désormais une voie réservée
qui relie l'école polytechnique au
carrefour de saint thomas
mais ce n'est qu'une première étape
d'ici l'été il ira jusqu au christ de
saclay voilà qui va permettre une
meilleure desserte du campus
il s'agit d'une ligne d'un peu moins de
7 km2 site propre puce qui vient
prolonger une première partie qui a été
mis en service en 2009 entre la gare de
massy palaiseau et l'école polytechnique
et qui est prolongé depuis l'école
polytechnique jusqu'au carrefour du
christ de saclay afin de créer une
desserte efficace du sud du plateau en
lien avec l'arrivée 2
nombreuses écoles entreprises
établissements de recherche logement
étudiant le projet c'est une voie dédiée
pour les bus continuent pour permettre
de circuler sans être pénalisés par la
circulation générale des bouffons le
matin il voit dédier une priorité
systématique aux carrefours les bus sont
détectés quand il approche du carrefour
pour qu' il n'est pas ralentir lors du
passage du carrefour mais le projet
s'est également la création en continu
de circulation piétonne et de pistes
cyclables
on est sur un territoire qui qui
s'urbanise le projet s'est construit au
bord de routes départementales qui
n'avaient souvent pas trottoir rien
n'était prévu pour les vélos et là on a
une circulation continue ed sécurisé
pour les piétons que pour les vélos en
plus de la voie dédiée pour les bus il
est édité diamètre en service sont en
attente d'achèvement de l'ensemble des
travaux pour permettre une desserte dès
l'arrivée d'edf lab à la fois l'ensemble
de la recherche et développement et la
formation continue d'edf qui
s'implantent dans la zac de l'école
polytechnique appropriée c'est arrivé le
site propre été mis en service de
polytechnique jusqu'au carrefour de
sainte 20 sur les deux tiers de la ligne
et les travaux se poursuivent
actuellement sur la dernière section
entre
le carrefour de saint thomas et le
carrefour du christ de saclay pour une
mise en service prévue cet été
et si le proto 204 aller à votre
rencontre ce lieu d'innovation et de
création de paris saclay s'apprête à
célébrer ses deux ans et il rêve de
devenir moby line d'aller à votre
rencontre sur le territoire grâce à un
proto bus pour l'instant ce n'est qu'un
projet on en débat active au proto bus
c'est un bus mais alors c'est pas
n'importe quel bus c'est un bus qui met
le protelos en 4 sur 4 ou pour aller
engager les innovateurs de paris saclay
là où ils se trouvent
là où le travail là où tu dis là où ils
vivent et là où se déplacent le proto
bus c'est un projet qui est porté par le
pays apparaît s'accusent de la manière
plus porte le poteau 104 mais aussi avec
transdev qu'un opérateur de mobilité à
paris saclay et qui s'est dit que les
mobilités s'est aussi déplacé des idées
et à travers le proto bus c'était une
coquille qu'on va inventer avec d'autres
partenaires pour engager des téléacteurs
sur le territoire
il ya beaucoup de pistes qu'on doit
qu'on doit creuser et aussi qu'avec
sommes trois grands axes à le premier
c'est un lieu de créativité de
fabrication mobile tout simplement au
lieu d' événement un peu particulier
c'est qu'avoir un but comme ça aménagé
pour montrer des start-up montrent des
chercheurs tentent associations et bien
c'est quand même assez particulier et
d'autre part c'est un lieu de test aussi
pour pareillement des innovateurs des
chercheurs des points qui veulent tester
des projets et bien qu'elle aille puisse
le faire là où les gens se trouvent
proto bus comme ça va être un tir lieu
et comme tout bon tiers-lieux nécessite
des ateliers de préfiguration pour
savoir à quoi il sert est ce qu'il est
vraiment utile pour les acteurs qu'on
cible et donc on a fait le 11 avril une
première ateliers de préfiguration avec
une trentaine d'acteurs
on a ciblé à la fois soit avoir des
décideurs industriels des collectivités
et aussi bien sûr des usagers étudiants
chercheurs habitants et ce qu'on leur a
proposées c'était pendant une
demi-journée d'être une bise nationale
être voir un commando comme ça pour
savoir est ce que le produit pouvait
vraiment leur servir sur les trois
scènes rock on a vu le de créativité le
d'événementiel et du de test pendant
l'après-midi à travailler sur ces trois
grands axes avec l'objectif de trouver
des solutions que le proto bus pourrait
apporter à des problèmes actuels nous
qu'à chaque fois avec l'objectif de
trouver des usages concrets et qui vont
nous servir comme scénario pour
développer la suite du projet après ce
premier atelier aura au moins deux
autres qui nous permettent de creuser
petit à petit les étapes du projet
notamment l'aménagement du bus à la fin
on savoir qu'est ce qu'il ya vraiment
dans le bus et on espère du coup comme
ça pouvoir aprr face et la faisabilité
lancée le bus et c'est la fin de l'année
2016 et commencer la première tournée en
2017 du proto bus sur paris saclay
il domine votre territoire du haut de
ses 66 mètres vous voyez derrière moi le
tout nouveau radar de l'aviation civile
un outil indispensable pour les
contrôleurs aériens
il va permettre d'identifier et de
guider les avions civils en région
parisienne nous avons assisté à la mise
en place de son radôme autrement dit son
toit c'était plutôt impressionnant
regardez ce radar servira au contrôle
aérien
il sera distribué dans les grands
centres de contrôle français il sera
distribué ici à this man ci sera
distribué à brest il sera distribué à
orly à charles de gaulle et dort d'eau
donc en fait c'est les contrôleurs
aériens qui vont recevoir les images
envoyées par ce radar et ça servira à
aiguiller les avions et à les piloter
sur leurs routes aériennes
aujourd'hui on a assisté à l'étape
finale de la réalisation de
l'ensemble de ce radar c'est à dire la
mise en place de l'antenne et du radôme
donc l'antenne sert à émettre et
recevoir les signaux des avions donc
c'est ça qui va donner l'image aux
contrôleurs aériens
donc il a été placé ici de façon très
stratégique parce que ce point est l'un
des grands points d'entrée en région
parisienne de l'ensemble des avions dans
la couverture
au départ il est vraiment là pour
remplacer l'ancien radars qui est à un
kilomètre d'ici et qui gênait pour le
développement du plateau de saclay la
hauteur de la tour béton et de 57 m le
radôme fait un diamètre de 12 mètres et
donc la hauteur finale de l'ensemble de
l'édifice fait 66 mètres pour un
diamètre de 14 m donc c'est l'étape
finale au niveau de la construction
maintenant derrière on va avoir tout un
travail de réglages et de mise au point
du radar jusqu'au moment de sa mise en
service et moment de pouvoir envoyer les
données d'une façon opérationnelle aux
différents centres de contrôle donc la
mise en service opérationnelle est
aujourd'hui prévue
pour le mois de septembre ce radar les
transports vous même vous faites partie
de l'histoire de paris saclay de
l'université paris saclay ce silicon
valley à la française un patrimoine en
devenir un colloque parions saclay s'est
tenue à l'école polytechnique pour y
réfléchir
de nombreux acteurs du territoire y ont
participé on est revenus par exemple sur
la place de la femme dans la science ou
encore de l'évolution de l'enseignement
nous y avons assisté
nous sommes des étudiants et étudiantes
de l'université de versailles saint
quentin en master 2 de l'événementiel
médiation des arts et des sciences et
nous avons pour mission cette année
d'organiser un colloque sur paris saclay
notamment sur le patrimoine de paris
saclay il ya quatre tables rondes la
première table ronde c'est le regard sur
la place des femmes de sciences à paris
saclay donc y parle de la parité
hommes-femmes et en plus de la place de
la femme dans la science ensuite il y
avait le savoir son enseignement entre
héritage et innovation pour savoir un
peu qu'elle était l'évolution de
l'enseignement pour des années et
comment paris saclay réussi à fonder un
enseignement un peu commun et ce matin
nous avions les acteurs de paris saclay
comment fédérer la diversité avec une
table ronde sur les réseaux de paris
saclay est enfin là nous avons une table
ronde sur comment valoriser le
patrimoine d'hier pour inventer le
patrimoine de demain sur tout ce qui est
patrimoine architectural et naturel de
paris-saclay tous ceux qui ont raté ce
colloque qui pourront toujours le
retrouver en vie
notre agenda à présent avec déjà ce
petit rappel vous avez jusqu'au 26 avril
pour contribuer à l'enquêté publique sur
la ligne 18 du grand paris express et
déposez votre avis en ligne sur enquête
publique ligne 18 points et faire à
noter aussi le comité de suivi de
chantier pour le quartier de l'école
polytechnique
rendez vous est pris le 3 mai à 17h30 au
plateau des projets à orsay enfin le
proto 204 je vous le disais il va
célébrer ses deux ans venez faire la
fête le 18 mai venez célébrer ce lieu
d'innovation et de création de paris
saclay voilà c'est la fin de ce numéro
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve très vite sur tv fil 78 et
d'ici là pour rester informé de
l'actualité de votre territoire une
seule adresse le pap est ce point fr à
très bientôt
e
nous